hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade how's it going
wait I'm actually back in Cincinnati now
yesterday was my brother's birthday we
had a lot of fun I gave him a new
present I got him a tablet computer so
he can draw on the go yeah it's really
cool and then my mom of course made
chicken and dumplings which aren't quite
the same as Cracker Barrel chicken and
dumplings mind you know what we're going
yeah we are going after we play this but
rocket Li I had so much fun with this
and wait is that fun Bob so we actually
found out that we can do splits pre
split-screen co-op here so we're gonna
play a whole bunch of matches online oh
do you want to do whatever surprise well
we could do I played this three or four
matches with Bob so whatever we're just
gonna find we're gonna find in we're
gonna find matches for three or four if
we get a four it'll just be nuts but
we're gonna play we're gonna alternate
we're gonna be on the same team then off
these same team four by four whatever
you'll see it yeah it is what it is but
this game is stupid fun and oddly enough
you're getting five nights at Freddy's 4
Oh finally
yes I'll be at that up too yeah yeah I
would get 20-20-20 mode right away
because people have told me it isn't
actually as hard as the past ones but
we'll see about that we have no idea
okay yeah it's on do it
oh here's home there's no this isn't it
at all when I dislike my Karla [ __ ] out
thing no that's the orange version you
didn't customize the orange freaking
huge
oh not being blue okay alright I'm
playing defensive you get owned I got my
look of the Irish flag so oh yeah bug
ball I'm of course rep in South Korea
because that's who I is
oh this camera thing is very confusing
want the mall follow yeah just turn it
just okay it just makes it a little
smoother for everyone else to watch her
that's what I've been trained smashes
whoa no they're not so good no Bob and I
depended a bit min so well for it oh
crap no I didn't have a shot on [ __ ]
oh damn it okay no need I remind people
that we are not not good we're losing
again oh we were losing against rookie
ranked computers we end up winning no oh
yeah we did I forgot we did actually win
then so ignore what he said yeah Gazoo
we're good we're going to on the left
I'm on the right but yeah I'm on the
left he's read it should be the same
according to the webcam that's how we
did it but we're kind of flip-flopped
where we are going this one that means
you get 10 points yeah destroyed him
because I'm the big bruiser if I go full
speed oh wow destroy someone so what was
there to be destroyed that was gonna do
it I'm gonna just try to destroy them I
only clipped one of them I could get rad
I have no boost I'm just gonna love okay
well we're all just waiting over here
how I flip help you flip by moving the
left okay there we go
you know making stupid rises will not
help you in any oh well sure that we're
thank you yes I did that no kid whoops
didn't do that all thank you is a flail
in the air that [ __ ] yes keep forgetting
you're me and I'm number two oh yeah
yeah I playing Laura throwed me that
well there goes all our testing for the
audio
I just want to destroy people who just
want to destroy well well I didn't
whoops okay well sorry sorry I'm sorry
get it yes please do that nevermind no
not well to camera I have no idea you
know I played with you so long they just
don't want to share any glory with you I
wanted only to be about me and what I do
said okay oh no I'm gonna guard gold
just in case they get a first touch just
gonna be back here that way I can't
possibly break anything I can't find
know what you're doing over there yeah
just hang it over here hardened
gol-darned go well yeah
my god
now we just got a holder or leave and
then we'll be fine
right yeah we'll be totally fine where
am I you're over here
I'm blocking goal right got it
oh well weird things are now here
I keep getting bounced around like a
little car because we are aren't we
technically RC cars here yes I think so
pretty sure that we're not actual people
in these cars because they're getting
blown up with some frequency here yeah
you don't just usually get back up and
get back in - no I saw you spinning like
a ninny huh come on okay
yeah yeah oh no no no no no no they got
wide open wide open spaces oh no I got I
got I got I got I got a ball I see just
random rainbow trails blown out of
people's asses I'm assuming that there's
a unicorn oh that's like just like
college in the same College don't tell
me that there's was that when you ran
Miamians yeah yeah of course
Wow we turn this game around sorry buddy
yeah well I'm not sorry yeah I'm going
for it okay hanging back
oh it went over me I'm upside down for
it oh no no no no that's why I said
don't
just try to cut pluck the one guy well
as long as they can't score three times
in the Nexus I will actually hang back
if I will actually hang back the
satellite you're closer tonight yeah no
I'm hanging back okay well I'm going
gold duty okay
I just I'm here to make sure they don't
score get it get it get it or just for
just killing time here get it oh I
thought we already had pink yeah thermal
pink sounds cool yeah I get a little
snowman for the next one
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching we're gonna play a whole
bunch more so expect more videos of this
it's so much fun it is stupid amounts of
fun so thank you again everybody and as
always we will see you in the next video
see ya
okay